how do we calculate the cube of any two
digit number without using a calculator
let's see another example in this video
63 cubed your 6 multiplied by what gives
you 3
yes 1 half on the left side we write 6
cubed then 6 cubed multiplied by half
and then we multiply by half and then
multiplied by half again so we get 4
parts the value of 6 cubed is 2 1 6.
here we have 108 and the half of this
number is 54 and then we get 27. the
middle two parts have to be multiplied
by 2 always
108 multiplied by 2 gives us 216 and 54
multiplied by 2 gives us 108 only one
digit in each part so here we write 7
and then 2 is carried forward adding
these 3 we get 164 we write 4 here and
16 is carried forward the sum of these 3
is 340.
we write 0 here and 34 is carried
forward and we get this sum as 250 so
here's our answer of 63 cubed using the
same concept can you tell me the value
of 42 cubed tell us your answer in the
comment section below
we just got acquired by infinity learn
and we wanted to share the happiness
with you
for a limited period we have an
unbelievable offer for you
do check out the links in the
description and the first comment below